okay let's take some phone calls today
our phone number is 6 1 7 8 30 for 750
all topics are welcome all questions are
welcome let's hear what is on the
audience's mind today first caller name
and where you calling from I was in I'm
from Klamath Falls Oregon all right you
know what's going on today not a whole
lot I was just I had a question on
whether or not you've ever had to remove
a video from your YouTube channel or go
back and read at the video because maybe
you reported on it a little too soon and
some information came out that made you
think twice or really painted the full
picture of that story generally when
that happens I mean we we report on news
sometimes when we report on something on
the show it's been like a half hour
since a story broke and so I try to
usually be clear if we have incomplete
information or that it's a breaking
story in general I wouldn't remove a
story from YouTube I would just publish
an additional video saying here's our
original reporting and then here's what
we're adding here's what we got wrong or
a correction but I you know they're
probably have been videos removed
because of technical issues where
there's just a major mistake and we had
to remove it and reupload a different
version uh and and certainly there
they're probably been copyright
takedowns when we've used a piece of
some other show or something like that
mean is there a specific video you're
thinking of I'm not offhand I was just
curious yeah yeah I mean you know what I
vividly remember when we reported on the
Boston Marathon bombing here in Boston
that we had just gone off the air within
a few minutes of the first reports of an
explosion breaking and we did a video
immediately and just basically said
here's what's on Twitter here's one news
report about this we don't yet know if
this is even for real of course we
eventually learned it was very much for
real and that that video ended up
getting some incredible number of views
and we said this is all early and we
will have more information for you and
we did that's generally my idea I mean
removing videos from youtube I I think
having that library there is a good
thing so unless there was some very
specific extenuating
circumstances i generally wouldn't
delete it from youtube make sense yeah
that Ian thank you so much for the call
really really appreciate it always good
to hear uh from people in different
parts of the country today's sponsor is
casper mattresses and i'm actually now
sleeping on a Casper mattress and I love
it and for a long time I was sort of
resistant to the idea that it really
matters what mattress you have and I
thought and sleeping pretty well what
difference could a different mattress
make and it actually makes a huge
difference and now I've been completely
converted into the idea that the
mattress you sleep on matters and you
can get fifty dollars towards any
mattress purchase by going to Casper
dot-com / Pakman and using the code
Pakman PA que ma n check it out there is
a risk free trial and return policy if
you don't like the mattress Casper will
come and pick it up at their expense no
risk to you Casper calm / Pakman the
code is Pakman PA que ma n try it